[Music]
hi my name is Annie and I'm an
interdisciplinary artist practicing at
the intersection of art and science
I say interdisciplinary because the
mediums of my work range from
custom-designed circuits that mediate
your vision to the chemical synthesis of
a perfume that smells like a particular
human to biologically engineered
apparatuses that control movement of
sperm I would say that I'm a
research-based artist and like many
scientists and artists and may work to
understand the world at the root of
where my work I think I'm constantly
trying to ask how do scientific theories
inform culture subjectivity and what it
means to be human
hi my name is angel I'm a graduating
student in the program for art culture
and technology my work at MIT has been
about looking at science and technology
from the point of view of a critical app
practice asking questions of what it
produces beyond practical empirical
knowledge and so my projects are engaged
with the mind sets the space the images
and the materiality that designs and
technology infrastructure produces
hello my name is Jessica Saren hland
my work investigates and unifies
opposing themes interweaving original
and found material highlighting the
incongruity of factual accounts my core
interest lies in the fluctuation of
knowledge how facts and the way they are
disseminated develop and change over
time and how this affects humans
relationship with and within nature
[Music]